وينضم الينا من الخليل الدكتور بلال
الشوبكي رئيس قسم العلوم السياسيه بجامعه
الخليل اهلا بك دكتور بلال شوبكي واضح ان
هناك قرارات تطبخ في اجتماع مجلس الحرب في
اجتماع المجلس الوزاري الامني المصغر ما
الذي يمكن ان يخرج من هذه الاجتماعات
برايك مساء الخير يعني حسب ما ورد حتى هذه
اللحظه يعني ربما يعني ابرز قضيتين
تناقشان الان في مجلس الحرب الاسرائيلي
ولاحقا في المجلس المصغر هي كيفيه التعامل
مع يعني صفقات التبادل التي تطرح والمساله
الثانيه مساله التعامل مع سيناريوهات ما
يمكن ان يصدر عن محكمه العا الدوليه في
الموضوع الاول برايي ان اسرائيل الان
لديها معضله المعضله انها تريد ان تتعامل
مع صفقه التبادل على ان الالتزامات التي
تقدم في اي مبادره هي التزامات كليه على
الطرف الفلسطيني فيما هي التزامات جزئيه
على الطرف الاسرائيلي وهذا مما لا يمكن
قبوله فلسطينيا بمعنى انها تريد
للفلسطينيين ان يعيدوا كافه المحتجزين
لديهم وبالتالي تجريدهم من ورقه مهمه جدا
وهي ورقه تفاوضيه لا يمكن استخدامها سوى
مره واحده بالاضافه الى ذلك انها تريد
تجريد تجريد الفلسطينيين من الاوراق
الاخرى المرتبطه بالقدرات العسكريه بما
فيها ايضا بقائهم في السلطه داخل قطاع غزه
بمعنى انهاء هذا الملف كليا فيما التزامات
اسرائيل جزئيه وهي ان توقف اطلاق النار
بشكل المؤقت مع اطلاق سراح يعني اسرى
فلسطينيين دون ان تحدد يعني اعداد الاسرى
وماهيه ماهيه او نوعيه الاسرى الذين يمكن
اطلاق سراحهم في هذا السياق هنا لابد من
الاشاره انه هذا هو السقف الذي وضعته
اسرائيل ولا يعني بالضروره ان هذا الامر
سيسك كل العمليه التفاوضيه لكنه يشير بشكل
واضح ان اسرائيل تناور في هذه المساله
تناور بمعناها انها تدرك جيدا ان الفصائل
الفلسطينيه لن تقبل بهذا الموضوع وهنا
ياتي دور الوسطاء براي الوسطاء الان سيحا
الموائمه ما بين مسالتين كيف يمكن الجمع
ما بين هذه الاقتراحات الالتزامات الكليه
المطلوبه من الفلسطينيين والالتزامات
الجزئيه المطلوبه من الاسرائيليين بجعل
المساله جزئيه من الطرفين بمعنى انه اذا
كانت المساله المطروحه من اسرائيل هي وقف
اطلاق نار مؤقت فلا يمكن ان يعقل ان
الفلسطينيين سيقبل سوى بان
يكون اطلاق سراح المحتجزين ايضا بشكل مجزا
حتى لا يفقدوا هذه الورقه ورقه تفاوضيه
مهمه في سياق عمليه حربيه لا يوجد حذا
ربما يرتقب اجتماع الوسطاء نعم على ذكر
الوسطاء ربما لهذا يرتقب اجتماع للوسطاء
مع ممثلي المساد والشبك وسي اي اي
قريبا صحيح ويعني التسريب الذي حصل حول
يعني دور دوله قطر هذا ليس يعني مجرد
عمليه توتير للاجواء ومحاوله لعرقله
العمليه التفاوضيه هذه احدى القراءات لكن
المساله الاخرى مرتبطه بانه فعلا هناك
امتعاض من دور الوسطاء لانه دور الوسطاء
مبني على ارضيه وقف اطلاق النار الدائم
حنا نتحدث عن الوسطاء العرب قطر ومصر
وبالتالي هذه الرؤيه المقدمه من قبل
الوسطاء بانه اي عمليه تفاوضيه يجب ان
تبنى على ارضيه وقف اطلاق النار الدائم
حتى لو كانت المساله يعني من خلال عده
مراحل يمكن ان يصلوا من خلالها الى نهايه
هذهه الحرب لادراك ان الحكومه الاسرائيليه
الحاليه بالرغم من سقف خطابها العالي جدا
الا ان هذا السقف مبني على ضعف وليس على
قوه ضعف امام المجتمع الاسرائيلي انهم غير
قادرين الان على القول علنا انهم مقبلون
على وقف اطلاق نار دائم وبالتالي هم
ذاهبون الى مرحله مفتوحه الباب بحيث يدعوا
ويحاجج ان الحرب لم تنتهي لكنهم مستعدين
للتفاوض حول مساله التبادل طيب كيف تتوقع
دكتور بلال شوبكي ان تتعاطى اسرائيل مع
قرار القرار المهم والمنتظر غدا لمحكمه
العدل
الدوليه
هذا مرتبط بطبيعه القرار الاحترازي بمعنى
انه سقف التفاؤل الفلسطيني بضروره
بامكانيه ان يكون هناك يعني مطالبه بوقف
اطلاق نار سريع وحاسم من قبل الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي لك وهذا الامر سيرفض بكل
الاحوال من قبل الاحتلال الاسرائيلي على
اعتبار انه لدينا مؤشرات كثيره من قبل
الاحتلال الاسرائيلي منذ اللحظه الاولى
التي اجتمعت فيها يعني هيئه القضاه في
محكمه العد الدوليه وتم مهاجمتها من قبل
اعلى راس في السلطه في اسرائيل لذلك
سترفض اسرائيل هذا الموضوع ولن تنصاع له
وسيضطر الى اللجوء الى الاجراءات
الكلاسيكيه المعتاده بالذهاب الى مجلس
الامن والعمد والعوده مجددا الى مساله
الدوري الامريكي لكن اذا ما كانت القرارات
يعني فيها نوع من انواع التسويه وهذا ما
يتوقع اسرائيليا بالمناسبه ان لا تذهب
المحكمه الى مطالبه اسرائيل بوقف اطلاق
نار وفقا لرؤيه اسرائيليه متداوله الان
وانما لمطالبه الاسرائيليين بضروره الحفاظ
على المدنيين وضروره المساع
دخول المساعدات هنا ستظهر اسرائيل براي
على انها تتحفظ على مثل هذا الادعاء وحاجج
بانها تسمح بادخال المساعدات وربما تتجاوب
بشكل او باخر مع مثل هذا الطرح شكرا جزيلا
لك الدكتور بلال الشوبكي رئيس قسم العلوم
السياسيه
بجامعه الخليل